hi there Steve again here continuing on
my Korean language challenge and I want
to digress a bit here i am going to
speak in other languages i'm going to
speak in Korean but today I just want to
mention the fact that I discovered
because i was surfing and and looking up
tprs teaching proficiency through
reading and storytelling which is very
much in sync with the way I think
languages should be learned stories
listening and reading and they have an
exhibit in Boston at the American
Council teachers of foreign languages
who have a convention there in Boston
November eighteenth to 20th stephen
krashen who is you know the Guru is
going to be there and I'm thinking I
should go there so I want to know if
anyone of you watching here is planning
to be in boston and is planning to
attend the actfl conference there to
meet with you know professor crashing
and all the other exciting people that
are going to be there it styles itself
as the actfl conference and world
language Expo or something so certainly
a place I want to be and if people are
going to be there maybe we can arrange a
meet up or something like that so please
let me know I attended the actfl
convention in San Diego in 2009 that was
the last time that's seven years ago
amazing and there were many enthusiastic
language teachers there and I met a lady
she gave a presentation and she was the
head of the I think San Diego State
University Language Center her name was
Mary Ann Lyman hater I don't know she's
still the director of the sandy at San
Diego State University language
acquisition Research Center that's what
it was and she said there are three keys
to language learning and I have used
this over and over and over again it's
the attitude of the learner the time you
spend with the language not necessarily
in the classroom listening to
explanations in your own language but
time with the language and the ability
to notice I don't know if dr. Lyman
Hagar is going to be there or not but at
any rate I'm going to be
they're so if you're going to be in
Boston or you would be interested look
it up actfl world expo in boston
november 18 to 20 and i am planning to
be there and let's see if we can't meet
up so that's all I'm going to talk about
today and i'll be back to their korean
grind tomorrow bye for now